hello my friends FPS journal here and
two weeks ago we had little problem with
with people shooting at me but but this
time I think I think we'll be fine so uh
welcome to weekly update number five so
I'm mixing it up here at here at the
Turner project you guys know that I like
to I like to mix it up a lot and so this
week I thought I'd be changing the
glasses so the shades the shades are
gonna be different every week because
because that's how I roll so today we've
got these shades I don't actually know
what they are like I'm not a I don't
know I don't spend my time like checking
out sunglasses brands but um they're
pretty sick so I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
rocking them throughout weekly update
number five also the microphone thing
you guys might notice I've got a road
level yeah microphone right there that's
sort of going to be the standard
microphone throughout the rest of the
weekly updates just because um well I
really like having them outside and
stuff and well this is pretty much the
only microphone otherwise I've got like
15 other microphones which I was going
to use for other episodes because you
know a new one every week but um but I
just decided that you know we're gonna
be moving on to different sunglasses
every week and maybe I'll use those
microphones later but that's that's the
deal with mixing it up alright so I'm
just mixing it up even more this week
we're gonna be doing questions first and
then I'm gonna be talking about stuff so
um so Facebook questions first where did
you first where did you first learn game
programming well I mean I've answered
when and how but where that's the real
question isn't it I don't know probably
like in my room that's yep in my room if
people from Poland are called poles why
aren't people from Holland called holes
and that questions actually got three
likes on it so I thought I'd address it
and I have no idea but I'm in all
seriousness Holland's like the
Netherlands and you called him Dutch sir
so that's why mr. Star Wars otherwise
known as Alexander the telson first
question last
like um I'll actually two weeks ago when
are you gonna make collision and Java
game programming series and the answer
to that is soon like pretty like
probably in the next week or two okay
are you going to record dayz video it's
probably not
I mean Daisy's an awesome game and I've
been washing Frankie on PC in 1080p I
mean watching his videos they're amazing
go check them out if you haven't already
Frankie on PC in 1080p and I don't know
I just I just kind of feels out of place
cuz I do them the same way that he does
them and I mean he's already doing them
so I'm probably not but I'm we'll see if
we'll say okay would you join a project
to do with animation I'm actually doing
a project to do with animation right now
but it depends what the project is
obviously so yeah I'm gonna ignore this
next question and I'm gonna move on to
why you never ever ever on your
minecraft server and the reason is I'm
really busy and that's yeah I mean I'm
glad you guys are enjoying the minecraft
server the only reason they literally
like the only reason that I'm honored
now is to record videos to show no craft
which is my minecraft series some
minecraft minecraft series on um on my
second channel so you can find the link
to that channel in the description of
this video but it's the mr. chernau and
that's my gaming channel so that's like
literally the only reason I hop on him
now but I am on it pretty often now
recording videos for arm Jenna cough so
go check that out
are you a doc
all right which episode will we be
making the game multiplayer episode 84
all right now it's time for Twitter
questions talk about the very bottom so
the best game I ever played that's um
it's actually a very hard question to
answer because I played a lot of good
games in my time you know back in the
day guys probably especially like me to
say like some really old game that was
waiting like 2009 in the nineties one of
the best games I've ever played like
hands down is Raymond right man 1 that's
in 1995 games pleas'd action one that's
were played it's probably for other
consoles but I played on PlayStation 1
in 2001 and I was like the first video
yeah my overplayed it was amazing -
Raymond one that's like the 2d one it
it's just it's just the best Rayman it's
the best Rayman first of all but it's
one of the best games I've ever played
so um romanones up there called ramona
wolf at to the campaign to that
especially like the music because it was
by hans zimmer that was that was a piece
of cake like that that game that game
was more fair - best called Judy
hands-down and one of the best
multiplayer games ever played it as well
so that there's just some - that there's
just two games today
I can sit her up there Far Far Cry 3 is
definitely out there as well but um I
didn't I just haven't spent that much
time on that game as I haven't on uh
games but um it's it's still it's still
really good really good game so there's
my favorite games of gasps what is your
favorite TV show Dexter Dexter probably
like I've been thinking I was actually
thinking about this question for like
the past few hours
and I think Dexter's probably probably
the I can't wait till season 8 it's just
season 7 just amazing so um yeah Dexter
alright do you like apples or are you a
banana person um I like oranges so there
you go but in all seriousness apples are
bananas I probably roll with apples I
don't know I'm not a big fan of bananas
like um they're not bad but I hey you
know I like oranges I do plan on making
any other Java tutorials yeah I've been
considering it but I don't know we'll
see how it will see how much free time I
have like I mean if I've got some free
time especially because I'm gonna be
doing software stuff in the university
if I find something that I want to share
with you guys I'll teach you then I'll
go ahead and do that but um so yeah
possibly
I mean well
say will you be planning on t-shirts
anytime in the future
t-shirts totally man I don't know I
haven't actually thought about making
t-shirts but um you know we'll see maybe
if I get bigger um but I'll be rolling
out the Turner a line of t-shirts so let
me know if you guys want them want them
t-shirts cuz something just landed on me
my favorite fiction character so a
favorite fictional character that's
that's actually I don't know because the
thing is like answering questions like
that like favorite something they're
really hard to answer no no not only
because there's a lot of characters for
example that I like but also because I'm
I can't think of every character I've
ever like seen or ever read about
fictional I can't like recall everything
and be like yeah that's the best but up
there probably the doctor played by
David Tennant that version of the doctor
that's what one of my favorite
characters as well as well I mean I
can't really say Dexter for that because
I mean he's a he's a he's a freakin
serial killer but um I do like I don't
know I like part of his character but I
don't know so there's that what else is
there man I'm gonna have to get back to
you guys on that one cuz I can't think
of anything else right now
so it's gonna wrap up the questions
compartment of weekly update number five
that's probably the most questions I've
ever answered as well it's like it's
like almost old and so um so yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed that QA that's gonna
sort of like the theme for weekly update
number five isn't it but um yeah I mean
there's there's ducks in this box so I'm
pretty happy
so um yeah so ducks other stuff that's
been going on so they might add for
those of you actually haven't heard
before because I usually trade these
weekly updates is like a summary over
the week all since the summary since
last weekly update which was done before
this isn't on fire obviously but um the
server my minecraft server my minecraft
mindcrack server went up it's been up
like for two weeks without crashing as
well this hosting company is brilliant
so shout outs craft your box that's the
hosting company that I'm with right now
they're really good man I mean they're
cheap and they're I'm literally reliable
I mean it's been over a week since they
filmed that duck right over there I like
that duck all right now back to me
but um yeah I mean it's been see these
pigeons just all over me so yeah I mean
they've been they've been awesome that
the support is is up there their um
their their server hard was really good
I mean it's the service been really fast
they've got like a 1 gigabit per second
uplink as well yeah their upload speed
it's just it's honestly one of the best
hosting companies that I've had the
pleasure of working with so um you know
it you can actually reach them on
twitter at craft your box so if you guys
could like tweet them and tell them that
like the Cherno server is just rocking
out and it's just it's amazing and that
they're awesome I'll actually leave a
click to tweet in the description of
this video so if you guys click that and
tweet at them I'd be I'd be much I'd be
much in debt to you guys because um cuz
yeah I mean you know just just let them
know that they're that they're doing an
awesome job because they are and I'm
really grateful for that and if you guys
want to actually get on the server
there's actually a video I'll link the
video in the description of this video
as well on how to actually get to the so
because you need to download FTB and you
need to get mine crack and you get all
that running but the server IP is
minecraft paterno calm so enter that
into mind into minecraft mindcrack
version 1.4.7
at least because obviously a later
version will come out but um yeah update
i've just if you should go to that and
you go to mine crack your minecraft
minecraft client and you put in that IP
address you should be on the server and
yeah I mean have fun with that I yeah
I've been doing videos as well turn okra
off season to cook kind of kind of
called it season 2 but it's really just
still shown across the trainer craft all
those videos are recorded on that server
so I'm go there build something awesome
maybe catch me while I'm recording a
video on there as well that would be
awesome but yeah so that's minecraft of
the channel a common and again the video
is in the description on how to get to
that so um anyway that's commit that's
going to wrap up weekly update number
five but big guys uh hope you guys what
oh yeah alright so one more thing I
wanted to introduce them to weekly
updates it's like a game of the week
type of thing just cuz um well just cuz
I want to do that basically um so again
the week this week is gorky's
zero this game is rated like 25 percent
or something it's like it's like
something like 13 out of out of 100 or
so I don't know it's it's rated really
badly but um it's a really good game I
don't know why I don't know why people
hate it so much but um unfortunately I
can't get it to work on anything other
than Windows XP although uh because it's
an old game but um I mean anyone's like
goofy there you know what I'm talking
about it's kind of like Splinter Cell
it's kind of like top-down it's kind of
really cool but yeah just that's the
game of the week this week for work me
up that number five because it's a top
notch game obviously this company isn't
paying me to say that because it's game
it's like 20 years old actually I'm
gonna figure out so 2004 so this games
like what is that like freaking 9 years
old so yeah but it's a really good game
so just um keep that in mind you
probably won't be able to find out
anything anywhere cuz it's this old but
dropping it but it's it's a good game so
definitely check that one out
alright so that's gonna wrap up weekly
update number 5 and I hope you guys
enjoyed the video if you did please hit
that like button and I'll see you guys
tomorrow with another game programming
video because they're resuming tomorrow
so um so ever have fun with that and you
guys drug video see you guys next week
later guys
you